what is going on everybody welcome back
to my youtube channel richard on data
and if this is your first time here my
name is richard and this is the channel
where we talk about
all things data data science statistics
and programming
so subscribe for all kinds of content
just like this if you haven't already
and hit the notification bell so youtube
notifies you whenever i upload a video
this is another video in my r tutorial
series
if you've seen other videos in this
series so far which i do strongly
recommend by the way
i've covered various packages in the
tidy verse
so things like the apply r for data
manipulation
uh ggplot2 for visualizing data
string r lubridate for all these data
types like
character strings and date times which
are a little bit more difficult to
uh to work with and then other more
basic things like your base r
functions as well as all the different
objects and data types inside of
r well we're going to do something fun
today which is
linear models so i'm going to walk you
through how to run
linear regression and logistic
regression
what exactly is being outputted so how
to exactly
interpret the results and what kind of
just
objects in the first place you're being
given and then how to work
with these things in a tidy format so
before we get started here
hit the like button for the youtube
algorithm the script as always is going
to be available on my github repo
that's going to be linked in the
description of this video and then if
you guys would be willing to support me
over on patreon
that's massively appreciated as always
the link to do that will be in the
description as
well so without further ado let's get
started so we're going to use
two different data sets here those are
the mt cars data set
that's a standard data set out of the
tidy verse and then we're also going to
use this credit card data set
it's a nice data set that comes out of
the aer package
we're going to come back to that later
in this tutorial for the logistic
regression example
there's documentation on these data sets
available for nice stuff like variable
descriptions
those links are going to be available
both in the description of the video as
well as
uh in the script but we're going to
start off with this empty cars data set
and specifically we want to fit a linear
regression
treating the mpg variable as the
dependent variable
and then however many other uh
variables that we can out of that data
set to be our independent
variables that is our predictors so with
any type of modeling exercise the first
thing that i like to do
is just run a basic uh descriptive
summary of my variables
so that's the first thing i'm going to
do here just use the summary function
on mt cars so when you
look at all these various uh variables
here
so one thing that i'm looking for here
uh
is serious outliers and i'm not seeing
anything too
bad here uh but one thing i'm noticing
here is that
the cyl variable that's cylinders
uh this vs thing it's either zero or one
uh there's am which is also zero or one
and then
gears this is taking on values of three
four and five so it's very obvious even
if you're not a car person
uh that these are not numerical
variables they shouldn't be coded that
way
they should be treated as categorical
variables that is factors
so i'm going to go ahead and make that
change to them
one thing i'm not getting into uh in
this tutorial
is multi-collinearity because that's
pretty much a subject for a separate
tutorial in and of itself
so just uh just changing these numerics
into factors for now because that is a
super common mistake that people make
when they're starting off with
uh with linear modeling so now that
we've done that
we're gonna go ahead and fit a linear
model our function for doing that
is this lm function here and there's
just two key arguments that we need to
know for that
the first argument is a formula second
argument is
the is the data so the data is just
empty cars
and you'll notice i have mpg uh tilde
period here that tilde period thing
that's just a shorthand notation for use
all the
uh other variables in the whole data set
so
convenient thing we're storing this
output into an object called lin reg
now we call this thing and it's going to
output
uh the model call so that's basically
exactly this line of code that we ran up
here before
uh but then the uh slope coefficients
here
so that's that's all well and good
that's nice
uh but if you're getting into this you
probably want more information than that
so generally speaking when you create
these lm objects
uh you don't want to just call this this
lm object
you actually want to call a summary of
the object
that's exactly what we're going to do
but there are a couple cool things that
i want to show you first
so first and foremost if you look at
these two lines of code
notice i'm setting this up a little bit
differently than i did the first time
around
so i'm not writing the formula directly
inside of the lm
function i'm instead defining this
formula
object first all that is is a character
string
and then i'm going to pass that uh
formula
object into lm here now i should point
out
this formula object here like there is
an actual class
called formula but the lm function
is pretty smart so if it sees a
character string like this
that can be coerced into a formula it's
going to automatically do that
so that's really awesome it's not
something that you have to worry about
for lm
and glm but it is an issue with things
like random forest and stuff which we'll
get to in later tutorials
now there's a couple other things that
i'm doing inside this formula
you'll notice that i want a model on the
square root
of this disp variable and i also have
this hp
uh colon wt thing going on here because
i want to just create an
interaction term here that's uh how you
would set that up if you care about
interaction terms
so i'm going to do that here so i did
all that
i'm going to run this summary function
now if you just take a look at this uh
give it a second to load this is much
more informative
so we have the model call like we did
before
we have a five number summary of the
residuals if you care about that kind of
information
and then for all of our uh slope
estimates here
we have the actual estimate we have the
standard error of that estimate
we have the corresponding t value and we
have the corresponding
p-value for that estimate so we know if
it's statistically
uh significantly different than zero so
you have your standard significance
codes here for uh
knowing are you significant at the 0.1
level 0.05 level etc etc etc
you have the residual standard error
that's the average size of the residuals
that's basically your root mean square
error you have your multiple r
squared and adjusted r squared and then
the f statistic for the overall model
fit as well as corresponding p
value so that's all well and good and
everything
this is super informative but a question
you might be wondering is
what exactly is this like in terms of r
objects that we're familiar with like
lists and data frames and things like
that
like what exactly is this and then
suppose we want to extract
parts of this output like let's say the
slope estimates or
multiple r squared whatever it is how
exactly would we go about doing that
well it's super important to understand
the structure of these things and what
exactly all these objects are
so i'm going to make you struggle with
this for a little bit by showing you
some things and then i'm going to show
you a super easy way to do stuff like
this
using the tidy verse essentially so
we're going to start by using the str
function to examine the structure of the
linear regression model
object so it's running
but even while this thing is running it
should be fairly
apparent to you this thing is kind of a
mess
like you can start to see things like
well it is a list
but it's a list of all these things like
a numerical vector of coefficients
residuals effects you've got your fitted
values
and all this other stuff going on here
like the qr
here is a list this is a little bit
challenging to work to work with it's
still running here
um you've got a model object which is
returned at the end
so at the end you're going to actually
get back your data frame
as part of the structure of the linear
regression object
so as in so far as just looking at the
structure of these things is concerned
it is a little bit more intuitive to
work directly with the structure
of the summary of the linear regression
rather than working with the structure
of the linear regression
let's work with the structure of the
summary
so you may want to save that as its own
object up front
but we're just going to call the
structure here
we've got things like the call the terms
the residuals the coefficients
a lot of other nice stuff r squared
adjusted r squared the f statistic you
get the idea
so this is stuff that you can fairly
clearly
extract if you're familiar with working
with lists
so what i want to do here is
let's say for all these parameters here
so this whole table with your
coefficients you've got your slope
estimates the standard error the t
value and all that kind of stuff let's
say i want to return
this table here and then i want to
return it
in terms of the t value so i want to
sort
by t value in descending order by
absolute value
so let's say i want to do that so
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
create a summary
of linear regression let's save that as
its own object
i'm going to create a data frame based
on
uh the coefficients because remember
this summary list thing
it's just going to be a list so we can
extract
coefficients separately so we're going
to do that
save that as its own data frame called
co f
and now that's just a data frame we can
work with
let's see what we get
you'll notice that i arranged by
descending absolute value of t
dot value because in this whole process
of creating a data frame
the names of these things got changed
around but
here we go we've got this we've got
descending order
of the absolute value of the t
statistics so
that is one way that you can work with
this output directly
now that's the hard way i'm gonna show
you the easy way next
there's a package called broom it's
generally considered to be part of the
tidy verse
family of packages but you do need to
call it separately from the actual tidy
verse
as i did at the beginning of this video
so
there are three key functions from here
and we're gonna see all of them
the first one is this tidy function and
it's going to return a tidy data frame
all this is is a tidy version of the
exact same data that we extracted before
but notice that this is way
easier all i did was one single line of
code
i just used this tidy function that's it
and look at that i've got the estimate
of the slope parameters
standard error t statistic p value
super straight forward clean tidy this
is awesome
there's this glance function which is
going to give us some of this
useful uh summary information so we've
got
r squared adjusted r squared sigma
the f statistic the p-value the degrees
of freedom
the log likelihood the aic
let's keep going bic the deviance
the degrees of freedom of the residuals
number of observations
this is awesome so one last
uh function to know is the augment
function
and this is going to pass into arguments
so
we've got the model object then you want
a data object
and it's going to pass a bunch of new
variables
into your original data set so if we
scroll to the right here
notice you've got a lot new really
awesome variables here
so you've got the fitted values the
residuals
etc etc this is really really awesome
uh it's much much easier than working
with all this stuff by hand
using uh the nature of these objects as
they're created by
uh you know the structure function and
the linear model function
but you need to know that that's the
hard way of doing it just so you know
what you're actually getting out of
these functions
all right next i'm going to show you a
logistic regression
and this is where we're going to use the
credit card data set
just like we did before i'm going to
just before doing any kind of modeling
effort
i am going to run a summary on the
credit card data set this card variable
here
that is whether the card was issued or
not is going to be
our dependent variable here and i'm
going to observe these things for
uh issues now there are a few
uh problems that i want to point out
here so first of all this share variable
uh it's in a proportion form now there's
nothing inherently wrong with that
i don't like interpreting proportions
when i'm looking at my
model output i would much rather look at
percentages so i'm just going to scale
it up by a factor of
100. notice this major cards
variable here it's another zero one sort
of thing so it should be a factor
uh rather than a numeric then you've got
this expenditure variable here
so as i look for outliers i'm looking
for things that are on the more extreme
side
and when i see that the mean is 185 but
the median is 101
the third quartile is 249 but you have
this 3099
outlier over here uh that's a little bit
on the outlying side
now there's a number of ways that you
can address uh
outliers i'm just going to exclude it
from the model
that's just the simple quick and lazy
way of doing it
so when i create this formula here
expenditure is not going to be a part of
it
so just like before i'm going to create
this formula object here
it's a character string just like before
it's going to be coerced into a formula
object
now we're going to use the glm um
function here instead of lm now we're
going to take three different arguments
here
first is the formula second is the
family
so uh for those of you unfamiliar with
uh
generalized linear models in general a
this basically corresponds to the link
function so
a logistic regression is going to have a
binomial
uh link function uh by contrast a log
linear model would have a poisson
link function so you would pass family
equals poisson here but that's
totally the subject for a different
tutorial and we're going to pass data
equals credit card here
so we're just going to run the summary
of that
and just like before we're going to get
really really nice looking output
so a five number summary of the deviance
residuals
we've got the same type of table that we
had before with your estimates of the
slope parameters with their
corresponding standard errors
their z values and corresponding p
values
and now if you're familiar with the
difference between linear and logistic
regression you know
some of the goodness of fit statistics
are different you've got things like the
null and residual deviance
that are outputted here with their
corresponding degrees of freedom
as well as the aic and so i'm going to
leave you there
in this tutorial you saw how to create
linear regressions
as well as how to access the summary of
them for all the more detailed
information
how to actually work with the model
objects which are returned
and then how to work with them more
easily using a tidy sort of format
and then lastly how to create a
generalized linear model specifically in
this case
a logistic regression now this is some
of the most
fun stuff i think most people would
agree that you're going to do
in r remember that r was built by
statisticians for other statisticians
and in future tutorials we're going to
go a lot deeper than this but for now
i'm going to leave you there
so thanks for watching this video if you
enjoyed it again
hit the like button consider sharing it
and then i'll see you all in the not so
distant future until then
richard on data